JavaScript an embarrassing toy language
used exclusively to build things it's
not supposed to it was created by
Brendan Ike in 1995 who was given
requirements to build a language like
Java but for words it only took him
seven days to execute flawlessly it
became an overnight dumpster fire but
[ __ ] really hit the fan in 2005 when
Ryan Dahl made the Epic mistake of
bringing JavaScript to the server with
node.js just like Alfred Nobel and
dynamite he would go on to apologize for
his invention many years later and it's
my fault and I'm very sorry the language
is designed for only one use case to
annoy people with browser pop-ups but
today it's used to build memory hogging
desktop apps with electron janky mobile
apps with react native and unreliable
apis with express.js no matter what
you're trying to build there are
hundreds of different game-changing
next-gen libraries to get the job done
that's because whenever a JavaScript
developer encounters a problem it will
instinctively create a brand new
framework and upload it to GitHub with a
bunch of emojis in the readme in fact
there are so many npm packages that Al
Gore is now predicting the Arctic will
be ice free by 2013 you have stolen my
dreams in my childhood unlike languages
people actually like JavaScript doesn't
have a mascot but they are working with
David Cronenberg to design one it's a
Loosely typed language and by that I
mean completely detached from reality
when you add an array to an object
obviously it returns a string that says
object object now switch the order of
the operands and predictably it returns
zero if you want a good laugh for
yourself try adding two objects together
you'll get object object object object
now with that knowledge what do you
think two arrays will equal obviously an
empty string that makes total sense
because the number zero is equivalent to
an empty array and also equivalent to a
string of zero and that means the only
possible same conclusion is that a
string of zero is also equivalent to an
empty array but amazingly it's not
everybody knows you never go full retire
it got this way because Netscape did a
focus group in the 90s with some
homeless web developers they found on
the street who thought two plus two
should equal 22 and of course that's why
2 minus two equals zero when a language
is this bad and this popular at the same
time it creates an ecosystem where
libraries like is odd which does exactly
what the name implies can get over 400
down or no 400 000 downloads per week
the fun thing about packages is that
there's multiple module systems like
common JS and esm so you never know if
the package you're installing is
actually going to work now if you do
manage to build something with
JavaScript it'll probably never see the
light of day because then you have to
learn module bundling with a tool like
webpack and it's just not worth it man
this has been my cathartic release from
over 10 years of JavaScript development
despite its problems it's evolved into
an awesome language in 2022 and I love
programming with it today is
Thanksgiving and I'm extremely thankful
for JavaScript because it puts food on
my family if you want to master the
basics all this reverse psychology
should motivate you to buy my JavaScript
course and if you don't buy it I won't
make any money thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one assuming
I'm not entirely canceled after this
video